I'm already thinking Jamie Foxx your
dating life has changed well yeah of
course what's out there no I do know I
like I have I've I've my life is getting
older but but people think I'm younger
because I hang out with Calle and all
these others so I see younger girls and
it's terrible
my and my and my daughter hates it
because like you know I still try to go
to the club I'm that guy I'm still the
club yeah it sounds horrible like I'm
close I'm like almost 50 songs going I
want to I hate going to Club LA because
I was going to one oh and these girls
pull up and I'm outside the clip I'm
about to go in the girls locker oh my
god Jamie Foxx mine what's up we go to
school with your daughter you going in
the club nice oh it's a open house I'm
gonna go see it so I'm not I just have
to be careful and then they don't know
like you know I'm 49 and like I DJ and
stuff like that so I was DJing just as
clubs these girls by the DJ booth they
were just so young I got so what how do
you that I'm 22 oh yeah I'm 23 and oh my
gosh she's ancient she's 27 I'm like wow
that's if the girl asked me how old I
was when I told them how old I was you
would have thought that I told him I had
a terminal disease with it so I'm 49
oh my god
a guy from 40 minutes let's pray he have
49
[Applause]
[Music]